suivre son chat ou son chien à la trace
c'est possible grâce à ce dispositif
un boîtier de géolocalisation attaché
sur le collier de l'animal est relié à
l'application my localise son origine
une étude sur les différences de
comportement des chats ruraux et urbains
le projet part d'une étude scientifique
exactement et donc on a développé ce
produit avec des fonctionnalités
particulières concrètement ça sert à
suivre son chat à savoir où il va
la nuit
alors est-ce qu'il chasse est ce qu'il a
un amoureux ou amoureuse le boîtier de
géolocalisation allumé le suivi peut
commencer sur l'application avec
différents modes une petite fenêtre
s'ouvre avec le mode poursuite la
position les lumières et le niveau de
batterie également quand j'appuie sur le
mode poursuite
ici il me propose de donner mais je mets
données de localisation je fais ok et
j'ai directement mois la position vers
mon chat le repérage fonctionne grâce au
système gps ou aux réseaux wi fi un
système intégré et configurée par la
société vous avez une puce gps
vous avez une carte sim industriels que
nous avons intégré directement en usine
depuis le début de la commercialisation
en janvier 2018 une centaine de boîtiers
sont en fonctionnement
actuellement la start up compte près de
250 clients dans le monde animalier